My name is Maurice Patterson.
I'm the owner and operator of
MMP Environmental Solutions.
We are a
commercial-grease-trap-cleaning service
and waste-management company.
And today we will be cleaning
a commercial grease trap
in a Mediterranean restaurant.
The function of a grease trap
is to prevent any solids,
fats, oil, and greases
from dishwasher or dishwashing sinks
from entering your piping system.
So, the cleaning process typically starts
with me inspecting it,
making sure it's functional.
Typically, you want to
clean your grease trap
about every three months.
I would say that it hasn't been serviced
most likely close to a year.
Then we unplug the grease trap
and we start to remove all the components.
From that step, we will prepare them
to be cleaned with a pressure washer.
So, right here, we're doing our pump-out.
We have the wand connected to
the high-powered vacuum pump.
We'll use the wand to pump
out the entire grease trap.
So, as you can see,
there's a lot of grease
sitting on top of the grease trap,
and you can get a glimpse of the solids
that have floated to the top as well.
For Mediterranean restaurants,
you're going to get a
lot of oils, cheeses,
you're also going to get a lot of rice.
The rice is usually the main contents
that sink to the bottom of the grease trap
that you're going to want
to pump out regularly.
I would describe it as yellow grease.
So yellow grease is typically grease
that's used to make fries
or things like that.
There's actually two
different types of grease
known in the industry.
You have brown grease;
that's typically grease
that's scraped off from pots and pans
that's traveled down into your dishwasher
and your sink, down to your grease trap.
And then you also have yellow grease.
You can actually sell it certain places.
They may recycle that grease
and turn it into biofuel,
things like that.
It's considered liquid gold.
Some companies will
actually pay them for it,
so they're incentivized to make sure
that it's not going down the drain.
Here, what I'm using is a putty knife.
I'm scraping just old food waste
that has collected on there.
Organic waste just turns black over time.
It's oxidized and turns black.
It's a health risk, mainly because
any type of overflows
from your grease trap
may come in contact with food.
We use a pressure-washing
system to make sure
we're getting all the
residual solids cleaned out.
I'm using steel wool just
to do a final scrub-down,
make sure I'm getting into
all the nooks and crannies,
all the tight spaces.
I do this right before
we do a final spray-down
with the pressure washer.
So, we dispose of the grease
at a water-pollution-control facility
that will accept the
fats, oil, and grease.
And there's not many
places that do accept it,
so it's limited, but we dispose of it
in an environmentally responsible way.
When grease goes down the drain
with the dishwater, it's typically hot.
So, grease or oils, when
they're hot, they liquefy.
When they cool down, they
solidify in the drain.
That may cause plugging,
which will in turn cause
backups, overflows.
If it negatively impacts the sewer system,
then they can incur fines.
They will have to buy a new grease trap
or pay plumbing fees to
rectify the problems.